if you keep biting my goddamn shoes cuz
these are some brand new Snoop Dog shoes
and that [__] starting to hurt baby T
you hurting me now man no leave him
alone watch out cuz get
in what up though it's your boy big
Snoop Dogg and I'm hanging out on
BuzzFeed and today I'll be with some
baby dogs aka some little
puppies be honest with you I have big
dogs in the back so for me to come in
there and hold one of these little cute
dogs is going to really offend them so
one of y'all may get bit on the ass on
the way out of here blame it on
interview what up do what's up little
homie that's Tyson what's up
Mike hey little
fella I was getting challenged in a rap
battle every day by these little bitty
kids on the set I can't make this [__]
up it was one named Ethan right this
little [__] would go home every
night and write four bars to try to come
battle me with and I loved his spirit in
his heart because every time they would
say cut he would just run right up on me
and start trying to battle rap and that
was so dope that he didn't know no
better he didn't know he was fighting
against a karate
master PP these nuts in your
[Applause]
[Music]
mouth we had a lot of moments Mike EPS
came in my dressing room and took over
the dress room as theing DJ and start
playing loud music and DJing and we had
to get to the set he just still in there
DJing and he smoked all my goddamn weed
he didn't bring while we was out there
I'm not smoking anymore or any
[Music]
less oh I'm not going to tell him myself
but uh a lot of things have left with me
in my older days I would have been like
I can't be in the video with these dogs
unless they all come home with me see
how he peeing right there you should
have let him pee he did exactly what I
said he was going to do but he's smart
though he didn't pee on me my mind's
telling me no you keep biting my goddamn
shoes cuz these is some brand new Snoop
Dogg shoes cuz these ain't no bubble gum
stop stop biting my shoes come here I
might have to take you with me I like
you you got hard don't get jealous all
right cuz you do
too you get to learn so much from them
and at the same time you get to teach
just like this youngster right here
peing
and marshan Lynch Lawrence Taylor us
three got to go get high first to start
the game before we and Michael Irving we
got to go have us a little power out
before we figure out who the other seven
going to be Dion s to bring in the
spiritual advice my boy Tony Sarah Goa
Terry Bradshaw ly Swan Mel blunt cuz we
got to have a blunt on the field then we
going to get legar blunt too we want two
blunts on the
field I don't know but these mother love
my shoes my feet and my goddamn socks
man that [__] starting to hurt baby baby
T you heing me now
[Music]
man but my kids are respectful though we
don't be in there like mother and all
that we don't do that we we converse
like adults you know what I'm saying or
sometimes we get misunderstandings but
it's always
respect me ain't nobody more famous than
me in my mother phone cuz y'all ain't
going to just double team the little
homie like that cuz get off your back
you got to stand up stand up there you
go on your feet what you going to do you
just up here just
watching my best dish is probably that
aloney sandwich potato chips in the
middle and then on the flip side would
be that Lobster thermod door but the
baloney is always easy to make get the
right bag of tato chips Everything Is
Beautiful I don't do all that crazy like
jumping out of airplanes and surfing and
all that [__] I ain't never want to
learn none of that probably I want to
learn how to uh play chess he don't want
no help leave him alone get him off you
cuz get him off you too raise raise
raise raise up on him raise up on all of
them now pee on
it okay get down there CU yeah get down
get all the way down keep him keep him
on the ground stand on top of him stand
on business stand on business no leave
him alone watch out cuz get down get
down
CU yeah let him know you ride in the
back seat when we get back in the
van Nothing But a G thing
Timeless we're working on one right now
and we're almost done
what kind of advice can you give to a
mother that can dance that look good got
hit records can sing in real life and
irrelevant I can't give user no advice
I'm going be watching just like y'all
you just up my whole outfit cuz that's
the one thing about y'all y'all drop
everywhere y'all go you didn't [__] on
me or pee on me but you left so much fur
on me I could make a whole Jack it out
of
your you done pulled my strength all the
way out cuz but I love you I think about
[__] like that I just do it I'm I'm
spontaneous I'm
audible
n shut your old ass
up that's what my younger self would say
to me right
[Music]
now all right CU you cry too much go
ahead let me see if you can handle yours
on the ground I don't know what's up to
her why if this up to you baby I'll at
me you know I'm available what you want
to do
[Music]
the opportunity to purchase Death Row
Records came from um good business
knowing people you know pursuing the
goal by getting it you know trying to
bring a whole new breath of fresh air to
it a new life of business revenue
streams you know giving it the same
feeling that it had but with a more Mass
Appeal to it where it's approaching and
lovable and warm and not so
threatening October London on Death Row
Records that's what I listen to the
most
the people that we've encountered that
have been able to change their lives and
change other lives along the way you
know the time that they put in the
efforts and you know the love that they
have for these kids to see them become
some in life if you would like to get
any one of these puppies they are
available at hit living foundation and
they're still young this is the best
time to get them check out The Underdogs
on Amazon Prime go check it
[Music]
out